so angry old man Biden is this kind of
bubbling understory that I really need
to see a lot more of and my dream is
that he gets the nomination and he gets
let's say physically incapacitated some
god forbid and then the party steals it
and gives it to Hillary which which is
not an impossibility at all and I would
desperately love that to happen I want
to see her lose three times
mommy movie you're gonna have a trilogy
right yeah mommy to come back for the
third time and get her final defeat why
does Dwayne Johnson fit into this cuz he
must have to garage he said he's gonna
run is that what's happening
I think it's wrong a four maybe yeah I
vote for the rock ladies and gentlemen
welcome back Michael malice in the
building there he is
hi how are you I'm great fantastic
what's been happening in actually no
first off Dave Rubin got you in a full
ensemble and I go I get you in a t-shirt
what's happening uh yeah well you also
this is Skype you wanna if you want when
you get a studio and out of bed room
then I'll dress appropriately I'm in my
pajamas see oh those are nice that's a
nice check on the bottom the bottom half
thank you and I've got nice farm socks
for no reason to hear from Newcastle
correct see I'm gonna impress you and
make you uncomfortable at me the one
thing I know about Newcastle which no
other American knows is marybelle I
don't know though what's that Marybel
was 10 or 11 and she's the youngest
person convicted of murder in Britain
she killed two toddlers and then she
went to their house and she's like I
want to see Billy and they're like he's
dead love and she's like I want to see
him in his coffin and they sentenced her
to jail at age 11 she's from Newcastle
she's a Geordie you didn't know this
that is the most harrowing story that
I've ever heard yeah and they left like
notes like oh there's murderers around
like a little kid handwriting yeah you
didn't know about this no no no yeah
yeah yeah the books got cries and heard
[ __ ] me
what a waste is son Michael come on yeah
well I've got I've got stories about
flaming Cheetos and stuff and you're
talking about like child
the child young child crime yeah Wow
come on then that's my life first
well I other thing is that's how I
learned about that Newcastle is a thing
other than the beer which I adore but
also the thing they discussed in the
book which you're gonna have to do for
me is they talked they said the Geordie
accent is like the most unique accent in
all of Britain probably not too far off
correct yeah so when you get really
really thick it's it's essentially in
another language we go yeah we're right
next to Scotland we all right which is
Carlos yeah which genuinely is another
language um so yeah this this some
people if you were to if I was to rule
you out into the streets of Newcastle
and just get you to try and translate I
think you I think you might have a bad
time yeah or a fun time yeah or a fun
time so come on tell me what's been
happening in your world at the moment um
I don't know I just I I have my shows my
I mean my books out last May I I'm just
uh I like you know being a jackass on
Twitter and just I'm not having a great
20/20 if you're having good 20/20 so far
twenty twenties been sick I've got a
question for you what is your favorite
meme of 2020 so far I'm of 2020 it's
been short you know there's been much
good stuff I haven't I
I am blanking I had there been any good
memes so far this year what are some
suggestions it depends on what you cut I
mean this standing on a box this
Bloomberg box thing I don't know if that
classes doesn't mean but oh my god like
that is just it's I don't know I've seen
better you know like that one no I I
mean I'm I'm a munchkin myself and
there's so much worse things to hit him
over okay don't you I think when you do
the body shaming stuff it's weak because
like when they say trunk and I can't
curse in this show
fire away Mon so when they talk about
like how Trump has a small dick it's
like okay like were you going with this
yeah I understand I got that that's not
the problem with Bloomberg the problem
is he's like a you know crazy person he
was our mayor I'm from Brooklyn you know
I remember his mayorship
mm-hmm what was that like it wasn't that
bad but you knew if you scratched
surface this person is dangerous because
he was very much a I'm going to manage
every aspect of your life for your own
good
he was trying to think of plans about
how to have Manhattan not have any cars
to force everyone at the public
transport he was I think you guys have
that in London where like the tolls on
bridges change depending what time of
day you use so like everything is this
kind of engineered from the top very
kind of benevolent brave new world kind
of situation so yeah I'm not I'm not a
particular fan of his you got this
dystopian future with Bloomberg at the
head of it if he got in power yeah I
mean cuz he's got a lot of ideas and
when people in government have ideas
that's when things get dangerous when
they have that power as well yeah
correct yeah
so have you heard of Wall Street bets on
reddit you know it's not oh this is
precisely your sort of thing so I
basically I have absolutely no structure
to today but I've just got a load of
individual facts that we key that we can
talk about and we can go through and
Wall Street bets is something I got
introduced to recently so it's a
subreddit and on here people make the
most insane trades like just someone who
will remortgage their entire house and
put it on Apple's stock going down by 5%
by Thursday at 12 more days okay and
just literally leveraged their entire
life purely for internet points from
strangers that they've never met Wow
there's nothing normal
no but it is very fun and if you have a
look there's something called the
dankest Wall Street bet trades which is
I do like quarterly roundup on YouTube
there's like commentated and it's all of
the dankest bets that someone's made and
that some of them are really good like
someone who makes like 200 grand in a
couple of days but most of them are just
people blowing the whole live savings
like taking money out of their wives
account to like and they remortgage the
house and do everything student loans in
there as well and then yeah everything
goes out the window you know check it
out okay that sounds very disturbing a
little bit not as disturbing as a
child's killing another show
Michael's so you should read the notes I
can't even repeat them the language in
them oh my god yeah okay I've got
another thing to talk about G cuz you
yeah super expert on North Korea right
but that's true we're not hearing
anything about it at the moment it's all
China saying that China yeah it makes me
sad because for a little window there
you know I went there I wrote a book
about it dear reader that I mean this
has been my work for a few years like
kind of proselytizing you know begun
behalf of these people who are all
slaves and trying to shift the focus
from the dictatorship to you know the
population there and it and it was very
disturbing to see the subtext much more
in the States than in you know I was on
the BBC you know doing talks on this but
this is much when the states where the
focus here is so much that Trump is the
devil it almost sounds like you're
wanting this to fail whereas you know
you should very much be hoping that fine
he's the devil but let's hope this devil
pulls out a win on behalf of these you
know people who've been enslaved for 70
years and now that it's completely
fallen by the wayside it's very very
discouraging it's clearly not as much of
a priority for the president and the
media and at while that happens the
people you know that once you go there
everyone I've met is still there you
know I see my guide on Instagram she's a
very wealthy by North Korean standards
she knows she's in a prison she knows
she can never leave if she leaves her
print family will be murdered publicly
to make an example that's how they do it
so it's it's very very disheartening
that it is kind of fallen by the wayside
and it's also disturbing that china is
going in a North Korean direction North
Korean has some North Korea something
called sungmin and in the 50s they
interviewed everyone in the country
literally everybody and they figured out
how reliable your family is visa via the
government and they slotted everyone
it's like a credit score into three
classes Hostel wavering or loyal and
this determines everything about your
life including what city you live in
whether you can go to college you know
who you marry and things like that and
now China is talking about doing this
kind of social credit system which will
determine whether you can leave the
country it's very very discouraging
although the Hong Kong stuff is
a little ray of hope yeah I was talking
to a data scientist a couple of weeks
ago and he was saying that because we
have gdpr in the UK you guys in America
don't really have that but you have some
data protection laws and China is just
like complete Wild West like yeah there
is no there is no limit to what people
can do so here's one insurance companies
are using people's GPS data on their
phone and if they find out that you are
sleeping consistently in two different
locations that is strongly affecting
your credit score and the reason is if
you're consistently sleeping in two
different locations it means that you
are likely to be in a relationship if
you're in a relationship you will get
engaged if you get engaged you'll get
married and if you get married you'll
probably get divorced which means that
you're a credit risk but isn't it also
if you're in two places you're more
likely to get in a car accident
maybe that as well yeah cuz you're
traveling or they're all they're also
using the speed at which people fill in
their details on insurance forms to
affect the amount they pay for insurance
really so if you feel they have a tie
like at the the scraping the data about
how much time it takes someone to fill
in and if it takes X amount of time then
this happens and if it takes X plus 2
then this happens and X plus 3 then this
happens yeah but there's a lot of
research behind this this is not based
on nothing you know like actuaries you
know it's amazing how quantifiable I
think most human behavior is most human
beings aren't really capable of you know
critical thought original B action so we
don't know where this is based up but I
don't think it's T leads no no no it's
absolutely so the guy that was speaking
to it's like look all that they've done
is modeled to two different things
yeah the AI that they've got that
working behind this isn't malevolent or
like nefarious it's not going like I'm
gonna pick out the old people or I'm
gonna pick out the people in
relationship it is that in the past if
someone has characteristic a Y and B and
they're just modeling that but the fact
is that you can't hide the data like
previously your date or about whether
you are in a relationship or whether or
not you are take a 10 minutes longer to
fill in you
social security number or whatever it
might be wouldn't have been publicly
available wouldn't been used at least to
effect that's very crazy that it's
public that's really because I mean I
bet you like there's a correlation
between people who watch modern family
and a beverage that they drink right
it's and some others show some other
beverage that's how data works but it's
that's very oh that's that's weird
yeah yes you know the most popular type
of porn is in India for men from men
India it's not [ __ ] cows is it no am
i let's say that Bobby are you allowed
to say that you are allowed to say it on
the podcast I don't know how you how
much you are supposed to say it that's
let me guess of India my friends it
might one of my closest friends is
Indian yeah so just to mess with him I'm
going to say man boy no like what is it
breastfeeding okay that's milk they love
milk there's nothing I'm not sure if
it's the milk I don't think I can rate
the cow but you're gonna venerate the
milk okay yeah I don't I mean you've
drawn you've drawn that line that might
be it I don't know why I just know that
it is I just know that it is the most
popular type of I've never heard of
anyone getting turned on by that no me
neither
but go to India Michael you will be
amongst friends and that's not my let's
talk about this cuz this is what I want
to know okay I have friends who are very
into fitness I have friends who are like
TV models they were on like survivor or
whatever so your job is to be an
official hunk right that's like your gig
and you can hand wave it away and be
like oh poor little me but that's your
gig right partly right what's it do you
use like dating apps is your experience
on these dating apps like being a girl
that you just get like thousands of hits
um much is a fairly consistent but again
what we talking about just there they
select for a very specific type of girl
that make sense yeah explain it to me
please okay so there is a very specific
type of girl who will swipe right on a
guy that has the particular
characteristics that I do and my buddies
that are the same and I don't know it's
weird dating isn't dating isn't
massively easy for me or any of the
friend
that I know that have come out of doing
reality TV and do the whole Instagram
game I don't know anyone who has a
really easy time of it I heard that -
that it's easy to get laid but it's hard
to get a girlfriend because the
girlfriend that you want are gonna see
those types floating around you and
think you're not interested in her and
at the same time it's easy for you to
get laid so maybe you're not as
interested and it's going to be kind of
self isolating and it's not as it looks
a lot prettier on the outside than it is
and the inside is that correct
to a degree I think it depends on what
you're looking for in a partner so you
know there'll be some of the guys
listening that girls that have been on
reality TV some of the stuff I've been
on and then like with them some of them
want someone else that is in that
bracket look at them it's like it's
fantastic it's kind of like inbreeding
but with a sure within particular social
circles but for me I'm like like I've
done I'm 31 I've served my time with the
dolly birds so for me I wanted I want to
try and find but if you go headline
title is guy who used to be on love
island and blue tick and [ __ ] like
that's what you see so when I'm when I'm
actually wanting to talk to them about
the guy that the data scientist that
works out whether or not you sleeping in
two locations that goes completely over
their head and to find the girl he was
interested in that
it's actually really challenging yeah
cuz she's gonna be put off because she's
gonna think you're an [ __ ] or or
complete two-dimensional my other friend
when he got very fit what he said and I
wonder if this has been your experience
like when he would go to the bars the
girls who he would want who are like
maybe eight because they've got a great
personality they are prettier than
average but they're not like at that
level where it gets annoying they are
put off and the ones who are very very
forward and aggressive like grabbing his
genitals are like the really
unattractive ones who just go up to him
and let him like me is that your
experience they're also the ones with
daddy issues
the one guy come up and do that are the
ones who are the real sort of freaks
when you and that happens sometimes I
mean it's still it takes a very very
ballsy girl to come and do that like to
be the forward thinking I'm speaking of
Heather Berlin who's an evolutionary
psychologist at the end of the week and
I've been reading up a little bit about
it and it is like there is no
essentially no species in the world
where the woman is the sexual
protagonist and the same goes for it
takes such a brave girl to come and do
that do you get men being openly hostile
to you when they meet you know or like
they're not what they're not like giving
you the I know I think these guys who
are significantly more alpha than I am
and they might they might do with them
but my livelihood last 13 years has been
standing on the front door and
nightclubs so I've seen a million people
walk past me in nightclubs because
that's what I do I fill clubs and I'm it
meant that I don't know my demeanor of
just kind of being accepting and
normalizing of just humans in an inner
kind of an environment normal social
environment I think seems to kind of
cual that pretty quickly okay it's
interesting there's never any of that I
don't know I mean what was it like for
you talk to me about your sort of date
it's not a hunk that's so I don't have
to I finally I got my abs in so I I feel
comfortable talking about this stuff
with you but it's very interesting how
people who are outliers physically what
their experiences are and how different
they are and how different from how
people perceive them to be
like if you again the guy have a friend
who's a model and she's complaining
there's two scenarios right one where
she's complaining I can't find a dude
well that's because you're a picky [ __ ]
but then there's the one where yeah the
kind of guy she would want would never
think to approach her cuz he thinks that
she would never be interested in him and
when you're at her level she doesn't
need to be dating a model dude because
she's like I'm gonna be the pretty one
I'm fine I want someone who can hold my
interest so it's at that level it's very
very weird it's challenging for girls
it's really challenging for girls I
think because of hypergamy right so
women tend right actually today up and
across and it's the problem the same
problem for any girls that are listening
if you are over six foot one like I feel
for you because you're you're having to
look for athletes you know that
basketball players stuff like that like
girls tend not to date men are shorter
than them so if you are and it's the
same thing goes for every other factor
about a girl if you're a nine out of ten
girl or a ten out of ten girl like the
guy doesn't want his mates to always be
able to say you're punching or like
you're a girl who
happens to earn half a million pounds a
year like your you don't want despite my
Instagram bio saying aspiring trophy
husband but most men don't want that
yeah but it's also at what they find is
when they're that good-looking the guy
presumes that the woman won't be
interested so they'll come at them very
aggressively and when she is obviously
not interested in this aggression then
they feel comfortable of being very
nasty to her but they're the ones who
have set up this whole kind of scenario
needlessly and it becomes self
validating it's it's very interesting
dynamic at that level davian's
fascinating man I'm rereading mark
Munson's models at the moment which is
like how to attract women through
honesty essentially and that's so so
interesting as he talks about the things
that he's discovered Mark Ronson knows
who [ __ ] like the things that he's
discovered make relationships work and
I'm super super super interesting
I got another young that we can move on
to but so flamin hot cheetos you know
who invented them no so richard
Montana's who was a cleaner at the
frito-lay factory Oh
so the he's now the VP of multicultural
sales for PepsiCo America the guy
couldn't read or write when he was the
janitor
and while he was there Raja Enrico he
was like the CEO of frito-lay had
encouraged all of the workers to act
like an owner okay I said he'd given
this big you know one of those like end
of your announcement speech type things
Buffett and people like that give more
time and um then this guy this this
Richards Montana's guy had decided that
there wasn't any Cheetos for the Mexican
markets Mexicans love spice and he just
started like [ __ ] around with some
Cheetos and made flaming hot cheetos and
now he's the VP of multicultural sweet
Oh IIIi think I was more of a cheese
I've always been a cheese doodles guy
myself you see in America you guys just
have the absolute like laundry list of
every different type of confectionery
and and
savory I'm sorry how many types of
Walkers crisps are there look 16
prawn cocktail Hedgehog
[Laughter]
sea chicken tikka masala what are you
talking about we could play this game
okay yeah you are right America though I
mean sometimes when I go over I don't
know whether it's just novelty but when
I do go to America I'm just blown away
that's some of the things that like the
breakfast cereals is one thing that
America does breakfast cereals so good
super super impressed by that if you go
to for the people across the pond who go
to the whenever I go to anywhere I
travel I go to the supermarket because I
love seeing all the wacky brands if you
come to America and you go down the
cereal aisle every cereal box that's for
kids the character looks like they're on
cocaine they're all like really excited
and their teeth are showing and you look
at it like this leprechaun is like is
cranked ha ha face
yeah yeah it's really but you have that
notice count shockula's really excited
about cereal it's like he hasn't slept
all night because he's been doing rails
and now here comes the chocolate to top
it off it's really nuts go look and now
you can't unsee it who has been upon a
heavy one all night all right next up
what do you think is the world's most
popular spirit by volume sold oh it's
it's
mootai from China Baiju IG oh sorry
abide you from China so the next it
tastes like gasoline have you got it so
I did something called the arduous March
so - I did it's twice I had fans chip in
money and we bought we did this once
with 32 bottles and once with 40 bottles
and me and my crew did a quarter shot to
see if we can get through all of these
yeah yeah it was all these weird liquors
the weirder the better and one of them
of the 32 the it was moot I guess his
type of buys you was by far the worst
nothing was even close to as bad what
was ripping it was a mix of like soy
sauce and like what's it like just
straight off the but it's so racist but
it does it has that salty like metallic
Scott yeah and then like me it was it
tasted like maybe some kind of cleanser
it was horrifying and that it keeps the
the taste stays with you you know in
your mouth and I think how it works is
they do shots all night and get like
really whatever the word for plastered
is in Newcastle and after a while you
don't taste anything I think is how it
works as it kills your taste buds spoons
the sensational works yeah yeah yeah
it's really bad $10 a bottle it gets
really expensive vodka five billion or
easier
Baiju ten billion litres a year yeah
Shaymin right next up drunk shopping is
a forty five billion dollar per year
industry okay
why'd you drunk shop you have a drunk
shopped I don't really drink cause I get
meaner when I drink I mean even usual
yeah oh god I'm just someone need to
take you to enter off you take me what
take your Twitter off you know no I'm in
a person okay right go you
yeah I'm Russian so we are very good at
being cruel and I'm also funny so then
the next day I feel guilty when I say
it's really nasty things
name is malice yeah now let's find a
malice by nature as Roger Hargreaves
would say I have never done trunk
shopping I don't think I have it's like
online yeah yeah yeah so probably 444
pounds is the average annual spend of a
drunk shopper clothing and shoes most
common purchase and Amazon is the most
highly drunk shopped shrunk and I get
home I'm going to bed I'm not going
online I gotta go shop
I suppose you know no I don't I'm just
thinking I'm wondering if this is the
married woman yeah not gonna booty call
you know it's not a you up 2:30 a.m.
text that she's going to send to like
rich people which by the way we have a
series called life hacks on the podcast
a life hack which will never be featured
on there but I'm gonna put on now is one
that a friend used to use he has a
broadcast list on whatsapp of 3 a.m.
girls 4 a.m. girls and 5 a.m. girls
and that is like in descending order of
preference that he was ender like what
you up to
and just broadcast it to the whole list
individually and then if they reply
great but if no one does then it goes to
the four am list then he sends that and
then if no one replied then it's like
the five am list and now it's like
Dante's Inferno very base it's Judas
being chewed by Satan I then right yeah
yeah I think you're right because I
think is what I'm gonna stop drinking on
that's what I go home hmm
and I'm not going online at all if it's
got to be what you're drinking by
yourself yeah so you double screen and
you've got like modern family or
whatever on and it's like a Tuesday 9:00
p.m. and a bottle of wine and you just
learn yeah and some soup for yourself
yeah yeah yeah yeah buy some more soup
right what else have we got here here
this one's this one's so good Michael
okay right so emojis are starting to
appear in evidence in court cases okay
and lawyers are worried when emoji
symbols are strung together we don't
have a reliable way of interpreting
their meaning okay yeah in 2017 an
Israeli judge had to decide if one emoji
filled message constituted a verbal
contract so this guy had replied about
coming to inquire about a house and he
was trying to work out like if the
monkey or chipmunk on the end was some
sort of positive reinforcement that he
actually meant that he was gonna like
come and do something with this house my
favorite series of emojis Kurt
Schlichter he's a senior columnist at
Town Hall he goes after the Bill Kristol
types Republicans and what he invented
was the fist the eggplant and then the
squirting water it's a classic it's so
much better than the finger yeah it's
really really great to Kurt for that
yeah yeah well you what I tell you what
you can tell a lot from a man by what is
most frequently used emojis are have you
got your phone nearby can we see
most III don't use the I don't do them
on the phone I do them I Twitter I'll
tell you what they are
okay I know that month out my head the
blowing kiss one yeah because if someone
sends me a nice tweet and I don't want
to write a long reply I'll blow my kiss
yeah or if I'm being a like nasty to
somebody else I'd be like or maybe
people ask your mom blowing a kiss the
other one is if I'm being really snide
and [ __ ] on Twitter I'll do the nail
polish one to signify the Queen itchy
yeah yeah yeah well you know if someone
says something like well maybe not with
that shirt on you know the nail polish
comes out and the other one I use is
although less frequently since Molson
era took over Brazil is the helicopter
emoji so the helicopter emoji and I
talked about this in my book is when
Pinochet took over Chile in 1979 in a
military coup he took a lot of communist
and non-communist apparently and in
helicopters and threw them in the ocean
so when you see someone on Twitter who's
being particularly egregious you just
reply with the helicopter and they won't
know what it is but everyone else will
but now that we got a guy in Brazil
who's kind of in that direction and it's
not that funny I've used it much less
yeah you gotta roll back on that but
getting yeah getting the sea is a very
good response to anyone to just that
needs to leave that needs to depart the
conversation yeah yeah okay fast fashion
is about is wiping is hitting the wiping
rags business so that's the wife I think
wiping rags so there's billions of years
so why fing rags it's a rag for wiping
Michael ok yeah ok
so 30 percent of textiles that are
recovered for recycling in the US get
used to wipe [ __ ] painters need to wipe
up their splodge [ __ ] ok like plus wait
so it's are they paper towels are they
cloths
they're cloths ok so it's like textile
material right so you're a an engineer
who's got to clean down some of the oil
or whatever on a machinery all this sort
of stuff and apparently fast fashion so
this like a do guys have like pretty
little thing and and kind of imagine any
dress that Kendall Jenner is on an
affiliate deal for okay it costs about
$20 and and every girl owns it it's like
a disposable dress right laugh a single
eustress or a single-use t-shirt that's
fast fashion
and okay these clothing quality is so
low that it's annihilating the wiping
rags business because they literally
can't stand up to wiping [ __ ] okay so
it's such such bad quality that once
you've worn it when you try and wipe
some paint up with it it just falls to
pieces I'm the opposite I am a big denim
collector right I've got 30 pairs of
jeans and the trick with the raw denim
is yeah but you wear it for years
because it breaks down and you get the
fades you know what I mean and it kind
of DAPs to your body and you know what I
mean it that's the fun of it right and
you almost never wash them so this is
the exact opposite of the kind of
fashion I like like I like it when your
clothes you know like if you have
corduroys where the whales have worn
down over seven years that's fun you
know what I mean good I hate this is
what drives me crazy this is my autism
speaking when you have clothes that are
distressed but you bought them new yeah
like with the faded logos that's so art
it drives me crazy I want to have that
t-shirt that's been through the wash 30
times and now it's the letters are
falling off that's fun cuz I put in the
work yeah you want to feel like it's a
shortcut to success yes
I've earned it this is my this is
exactly yeah I'm I'm a man who probably
shortcuts that but then I I buy cheap
stuff I mean I spend my night surrounded
by drunken students on the front door of
a nightclub I don't want anything nice
everything I own is destroyed how
annoying is it do that are they all up
in your face about the show and about
insta um they were when it was a little
bit more recent so it's been like four
and a half years now um a little bit
more I got barred from the front door of
my own event by my business partner
Bikel because when I would walk around
outside there would just be this throng
of people that would like like cats
jumping up and down or something
but that that's candy that's kind of
chilled now so I can actually do my job
again which is which is nice do you get
hit out more by chicks if I do
chicks I give off a real bad gay vibe
it's just really yeah my gaydar oh I
don't know how it works my gaydar is
accurate for the people but my like
appearance on the gaydar for people that
are gay no ha I thought the pretty guys
get a hit on the most I did not know
this okay interesting I'm not sure we
were asking this question the other day
I want to know if you're a gay man how
do you know if you if you're like a top
or a bottom I've no I I don't know what
do you know I mean that if you're
listening and can you please explain
like to use do sometimes swap is it a
you know is it always a one a one-way
street type thing I want to know cuz I
mean on Grindr
you can choose whether or not you're top
or bottom oh I thought I'd be able to
choose both like how'd you know
and what if two tops arrived or two but
well I I think the analog would be do
you like choking her in bed or do you
like getting choked in bed right but you
can still have sex either way right but
it's more like which is the more
dominant and which is the more submit I
don't know I think we're talking about
things we're not really familiar with
that way yeah we definitely aren't that
it's definitely correct what else have
we got here
Oh mushrooms mushrooms and truffles are
more closely related to humans than they
are to plants yeah cuz of the proteins
yeah and they breathe in I only found
this out the other day that they breathe
in oxygen and breathe out carbon dioxide
what the [ __ ] yeah yeah there and that's
why they're used as meat analogues I
didn't know this yeah yeah so baby if
you think about how fungus works it
basically breaks down plant matter into
its own form so in a very very primitive
way that's like eating mm-hmm mm-hmm
yeah they split off so there was plants
at the top and then Oh some plants split
off but after us and plants spit off us
and fungi split off so we thought I
thought fungi came before plants no no
Oh interesting
okay so we are we are part of a lineage
that's after that okay that's very cool
yeah yeah I thought that was interesting
and then I mean Paul Stamets has got all
this stuff right where he goes on about
the mycelium under the floor that can
talk to each other a million miles away
and all this stuff I just got a fossil
of something called diggin Soniya which
looks like like a quilted circle and for
long time they didn't know whether it's
a fungus or a jellyfish or a plant or
since it's the oldest fossil or
something that is not related to
anything contemporaneous and then
somehow they found cholesterol molecules
and won the fossil so now they know is
actually an animal so it's really weird
how things that look nothing like us
just based on the chemical composition
we can figure out what it is right
because fungus looks so different some
fungus don't have fruiting bodies their
complete parasitic whatever telephoto
nail fungus it doesn't look like a
mushroom to us right we don't know if
it's a virus and infection you know
bruise just about just the thing and we
can look based on how for billions of
years there's certain things that have
stayed the same is that weird it's crazy
man I absolutely love thinking about
that stuff you've mentioned there you
mentioned a couple of times buying stuff
random [ __ ] from the internet what have
you been yeah Speight funding recently
and can you for the people who don't
know what that is can you explain what
it is so I had this idea once when
someone came for me on Twitter I said it
would be a real shame if people gave me
money for something I didn't want just
despite you and the donations kept
coming in I have a bunch of stuff right
here I'll show you and I'm like alright
so here I have this is a pen you're not
gonna have to see it really made out of
for tight for tight is what happens in
factories when after years of hand
spray-painting it makes layers and
layers and layers and it's kind of a
synthetic mineral so this is a pen made
out of four tight this is another pen
this from this is from a Corvette
factory that was cool
then I have a pen stand made out of a
walrus tusk I did not need this but they
paid for it after a while it gets harder
hard to find things to buy this is a pen
from South Africa made out of a warthog
tusk oh my god I don't need seven pens
this pen is made and right much do you
ever write have you ever written
anything right not with my fence this
one is made of wood from the DMZ between
the Koreas that's pretty cool that's
cool yes [ __ ] it else do I have here
huh yeah who has got hold of that piece
of wood so the guy who made it his his
friend was
stationed in the South Korean Park any
branch and send it back to maintain it
so yeah it's really fun despite funding
thing I just I'm looking right now with
a signed photo of Andy Kaufman who is my
hero I'm hanging above my my head so
it's really fun a stick to do what else
we're getting you thinking about
anything else at the moment or is it
just out of spur-of-the-moment I'm got a
pair of tribal print pants corduroys
from Japan in honor of Elizabeth Warren
but someone bought them from under me so
the money's still in escrow but that was
it yeah
and when camel Harris I don't know how
God familiar they are with her over
there she was this cop who was running
for president just really an abomination
of a human being so when she lost we had
a ham because the pig was roasted I
guess he called him the filth over there
right
we had a ham roasting ham tasting I had
this Spanish ham and all the hamster all
over the world
yeah actually oh that's really fun let
me try something interesting the first
time I didn't interview the BBC and this
is a very shocking moment to me and I'm
gonna offend some people and I apologize
in advance I was born in Russia so the
way the Soviets Russians look at the
police is very different from the States
and I was doing an interview in BBC four
or something and they said oh this
website you work on you guys make a lot
of jokes about the police and I thought
you know Britain's much more left in the
States and I said well it's like my dad
always told me and this is true like
wherever you go on earth and whenever
you find yourself the dumbest people the
cops and they audibly gasped and they go
this is a family show and they change
the subject and that was the first time
I realized how that is politically
incorrect to say it was very jarring
because I wasn't cursing or anything
how would that joke have gone down in
America oh it would not go down here
here would be very controversial I get a
lot of heat for it so I bite my tongue
and I'm like I didn't realize the Animus
was out of a portion - were the very
weak bit of humor that there was to it
and you just didn't think you didn't
know how I was gonna learn I didn't
think it was gonna land bad at all
because this is Europe so I assumed it
was going to be the same as in
Russia and it was not it was much closer
to the States
yeah it is what else would we go oh no
babies born in Britain in 2016 were
called Nigel you know how I love him and
I'm in love with him I have a few
friends that called Nigel that are dying
breed he is I met him at the studio once
and I go to him
mr. Faraj what do you think of Enoch
Powell and he goes he's an interesting
man very interesting and I'm like all
right I got you
well that's what Russell Brand call the
new me called him the pound shop Enoch
Powell Diddy yeah Russell Brand who
referred it to him I think on question
time as they sat on the same panel he
was like five yards away from him and
said he's the pound shop Enoch Powell do
people in the UK not appreciate the
savagery when he goes to the European
Parliament and basically takes a [ __ ] on
the desk
I think British people have a very
unique sense of humor sure and I
actually don't think that they find what
Farraj does as funny as what Farraj does
is okay that makes sense yeah because
when to me that I don't know how many
people saw it like when it breaks it
finally happened and he gave his little
speech and they all got up and started
waving their little Union Jack's it was
so so stupid and so so funny and then
the lady at the front of rooms like sit
down and get your flags Alerus and i
it's not meant to be taken seriously at
all it's clearly clownish intentionally
and I I don't I I am people here and in
the States get very very upset by Trump
tweets when they're stupidest thing ever
and I'm like how are you giving this the
power so yeah I get it's the president
but this in all the things he's done
this is the one that gets you upset that
he's you know making fun of this person
I mean how are you how are you how do
you have this much energy to be this
triggered after this much time this is
what I replied to you on Twitter
yesterday you retweeted a video of some
people protesting outside of the White
House ringing bells and
yeah shame and the first thought into my
mind was I don't understand how these
people have so much time right I dream
of having that much spare time that I
could go and do that I need to manage my
schedule more efficiently I'll get them
into it if they need to be doing more
drunk shopping they do what they've
bought obviously [ __ ] Richard we've
bought this Bell from Amazon I was
wasted what am I gonna do with it why
don't we go to the White House and then
it'll look we'll post hoc
rationalization make it look like it was
social justice yep the only it's tax
deductible yeah it was used as part of
content let's start I mean you know this
year 2020 all that's gonna happen is
election [ __ ] right like it's that's all
that's going on how do you see the rest
of this year playing out what's going to
happen I saw tonight as as we record is
the Iowa prime caucuses which is the
first voting in the Democratic
nomination and over the last week it's
become full-blown warfare between the
establishment and the Bernie Sanders
people which I absolutely love any kind
of political carnage depending on what
happens tonight it looks like it's gonna
get very very very ugly very very very
quickly
Bernie has already been launching ads
explicitly attacking the Democratic
Party which i think is historically
unprecedented he says they add like we
make Trump nervous we make the insurance
companies nervous we make the Democratic
establishment nervous I don't think
that's real even Trump never really went
after the quote unquote Republican
establishment yeah so he and he's
surging so if that is validated by a win
I don't know what they are already
talking the DNC Democratic National
Committee what they can do to stop this
guy so it might get even more public and
even more brazen out you might not have
seen this across the pond but you know
Elizabeth Warren said he said to her
that a woman can't get elected president
they try to play it off like he's saying
a woman shouldn't get elected president
and on MSNBC one of our networks which
is failing badly
Joanne Reed had a body language expert
to prove that Bernie was lying I mean
this is basically a tea leaves it was so
to be that brazen and I'm hardly a
Bernie person is going to be great that
we're
see unprecedented machinations on both
sides of the Democratic Party and but
you're having the same thing you have
the real life to Tonya McGrath Rebecca
long Bailey about to take over for
Jeremy Corbyn and she's saying that
inequality keeps her up at night it's
like get some rest [ __ ] calm down yeah
I mean that what is going to happen in
the UK the thing about the UK is
politics is so short-lived for us like
in America
ever since 2016 all that anyone in
America is wanted to talk about is how
did Trump get elected then there's like
the great hack on Netflix which was that
documentary about how the Cambridge
analytical scandal then the cycle if
Ukraine stuff then there's impeachment
stuff then there's Russian hacking and
Russian Bop farms and and it's just been
for years constantly of like post hoc
rationalization
right and yes with the UK as soon as so
on the couple of weeks leading up to the
election there was all rousing people
with roses in their bio and and and for
the many not the few and all this stuff
yeah two weeks later it's all foregone
two weeks later love islands on or so
that I missed celebrity get me out of
his on ITV on the TV channel so they
just call him someone a fat [ __ ] on TV
that's all that's all that happens what
was your reaction when you saw Diane
Abbott wearing and the different ones I
mean that I actually love her like I
love her a lot because here's what
people make fun of her we have people
like dynamit here the thing where I
think I really respect her is she knows
how to stick to it the message right she
was on with Piers Morgan and he's like
what's Labour's plan for immigration and
she's like piers the Tories don't it's
not working and it's disaster he's like
okay fine what's your plan I've told you
piers the Tories and I'm sitting there
I'm like I respect a politician who's
getting punched in the face and is not
reacting that takes skill and that takes
fortitude I'm not being ironic or
sarcastic because here they get
flustered they they freaked out so she's
disciplined so it's a I find her very
very interesting when you see that
single-mindedness so we saw her on
election
as soon as the exit polls happened
someone somewhere in the labour party
had trickled down call it a brexit issue
call it a brexit vote and that was all
you heard from the first guy that came
out and then I can't remember who it was
one of the panel pundits on this side of
the BBC had managed to get a leaked a
message memorandum type thing that had
gone round which was like right this is
the party line and he was freed him
through this leaked thing on air and
just saying I'm just saying like yeah
they're just saying just focus on brexit
call it a brexit issue because then the
fingers kind of not really pointed at
the fact that we didn't have any good
policies yeah and then regs it's gonna
be resolved so now we could have a clean
slate next time yeah which I don't think
is gonna change anything either okay so
we've got that with with Bernie moving
forward have you got do you put your
money where your mouth is with stuff or
what's gonna happen later this year or
not you do not do that this far oh I put
my money where my mouth is that I
donated money to Biden because I want a
year of him campaigning he just recently
went to the coal miners and told them if
you know how to cost shovel coal you can
learn how to program a computer which is
a lie that's not accurate I know if
someone knows how to use the computers I
mean they can shovel coal either so his
son being an admitted crackhead the fact
that we can use the word crackhead and
have to be funny again whenever heap
tweets I always tweet with the response
of a crack pipe reply to me that's not a
crack pipe that's a meth pipe and a
foolish of me not to know the
distinction between the two or they
correct me he's not the crackhead his
son is the crackhead so I want a year of
this plus he's been getting very very
feisty on the campaign trail he's been
yelling at people he's been turning his
backs on them he's been telling them to
vote for Trump so angry old man Biden is
this kind of bubbling understory that I
really need to see a lot more of and my
dream is that he gets the nomination and
he gets let's say physically
incapacitated some god forbid and then
the party steals it and gives it to
Hillary which which is not an
impossibility at all and I would
desperately love that to happen I want
to see her lose three times
mommy movie you're gonna have a trilogy
right yeah need the money to come back
for the third time and get her final
defeat why does dwayne johnson fit into
this cuz he must have to croc he said
he's gonna run it something is not
what's happening
I think it's will the road before maybe
yeah I vote for the rock runs for his
third term come on so wait let me ask
you this mr. fitness guy how do you stay
motivated on a cut and how do you
psychologically handle losing the
strength those my peeps are the toughest
part because I was gym last week and my
lifts were all down and it's like what's
the point
well you know you did the brain [ __ ]
with itself mm-hmm so the problem you've
got when you're training for aesthetics
and not performance yes
that your progress in the mirror is
always going to be subjective not
objective so if you were training purely
for strength you would know last week I
lifted X this week I lifted X plus five
good whereas you could wake up 2% leaner
than you were a month ago but being a
[ __ ] headspace look at yourself in the
mirror and go I look [ __ ] [ __ ] I
really don't like the this or I'm not
whatever
scales are lying whatever it might be so
I think what he said it also the truck
I'm sorry it's also when you have hunger
and you have the calorie depletion your
brain is also going to tell you negative
things it's you're not in a positive
place like when you're stuffing your
face and you have all the carbs and
endorphins but diet brain so it's well
yeah when you're on a diet all you can
think about is the next bit of food like
I just want more and it's the same thing
I was talking to Morgan Housel you know
Morgan is wrote for a big big sort of
Wall Street adviser and personal finance
guy and we were talking about debt brain
it's like if you're in debt like
civilian debt and you don't know where
the next meal or the next payment on the
credit cards coming yeah
it's precisely the same as diet right so
in terms of how you can kind of keep
motivation of it's challenging man like
a diet will turn anyone crazy I have a
friend I think I say regiment girls have
diets men have regimens and has the word
men in it
correct nice nice Reggie MXN
[Laughter]
it's challenging man so the best thing
that I can say is just to kind of stick
to the process like if you just continue
to stick to whatever the plan is that's
in front of you ensure that you're
having a refeed a refeeding when you so
you're in a calorie deficit and then
you're having one day that I know I
should start doing that I think so as
long as you don't have such a high day
that it bumps your total weekly calories
then over into a surplus but let's say
that let's say that you're on e tracking
calories I do macros yeah yeah so do you
know what you do you know your macros oh
I I can tell you sure you know hold on
let me up at the file what do you weigh
I am I dropped it I'm down to 137 137
yeah well I'm also five six yeah yeah
but still 137 137 at five six is
alignment
you must allocate that's why the ABS
have come in there right
oh yeah and the comm gutters too I'm
very excited 176 protein yep 175 carbs
and 51 fat that's good yeah that's good
that's nice I think that's what's that
probably about 2100 cars I think for the
day something like that I think
approximate my friend said they are
about just worth 2000 yeah yeah got you
so I think if you're doing two thousand
two thousand and then if you had one
load a and then one day where you maybe
did to five and allowed yourself to eat
a little bit more and chose okay shows
that on a day when you you know that
you're going to really lift and then
you're actually going to go in you're
gonna feel a little bit more full and
you're going to feel a little bit more
energized to go into the gym and stuff
like that so it's like that it's not
it's also easier psychologically because
you you have to tell yourself I just got
to hang in till Saturday yeah and then I
have more okay that's very helpful
another thing as well to consider is
anyone that's listening that's ever been
on a diet will get on a regimen
well they is regimen I had Andrew Doyle
on creator of titania McGrath in LA how
am i eating okay and I said to him like
Oh Andrew we have to take the faggiest
photo ever so if you go to my Instagram
there's a picture of us feeding each
other pink ice cream the result picture
me wiping it off his cheek because he's
a girl right you know what I mean and
it's really really fun he's hilarious I
adore him dude so he was citing my site
my living room now he's playing at the
Edinburgh Fringe and he was going to
London to be on Sky News and then
getting the train up and the train goes
past my house essentially stopped off
came in had a coffee [ __ ] off up there
my I was in I couldn't breathe there was
some of the things that comes out with
you so I adore him yeah have you seen
that him and Douglas Murray are both
touring the UK no that's awesome as a
pair that's amazing Douglas opposed to
be on my show but he couldn't get like
the licensure to get to the States or
something these are the outlaws from oh
speaking of the state's I just saw
something else I got spite funded you're
not gonna be able to make this out this
is it's not gonna focus this is the
first any ever made from 1787 designed
by Ben Franklin and on it it says mind
your business if you love I watch you
watch it oh yeah CIO it's the first
penny yeah oh how much was that it was
only a two hundred dollars for the first
penny in America yeah that's not that
much it goes for much more yeah I know
that's what I mean yeah 200 first penny
from 1787 I've been like I don't know
like some that literally first one I
mean there were generations I got it
there's not gonna be many of them
floating around correct and especially
not in good condition where those the a
lot of them the slogans weren't off I'm
like no no I have to see mind your
business is that great you should get I
should wear it around your neck or
something like that
oh my oh that's not a bad idea
melt it down and turn it into like it's
something else I was gonna frame it and
have a right Lynn you walk into my house
like a nice little frame mm-hmm
I died or in the bathroom or some I
don't know I love it I gotta find a
frame for it
that's all later okay so we wrote we're
rolling the clock forward we're getting
to later in this year and then what
happens what happens okay to two
scenarios first one is Trump versus
Biden second one is Trump vs. Bernie
what happens when they actually standoff
against each other I don't think that
the Democratic Party will allow Bernie
to be the nominee
how did they sabotage that I don't know
how they would do it whether they would
change the rules at the last minute
there's a lot of corporate power
the Democratic Party and I'm sure with
the Labour Party to they they pretend
their self for the people corporate
power is powerful you know every country
in all parties right
they will these corporate Bernie's no
joke
when it comes to democratic socialism
and you know contempt for corporations
and corporate power in America he means
that he's been saying this for decades I
don't know what they will do but they
will do whatever it takes because as
we're seeing here you're not you guys
aren't privy to it
the media has now started jumping
against him in collusion with the
Democratic Party so what the press did
against Trump in 2015-16 they're going
to do against Bernie they're going to
start dropping things I am absolutely
certain they will never let him be the
nominee
let's but let's pretend that he does
somehow let's potentially if it's Trump
versus Biden it is going to be the it's
not often we get to see an old man
beaten and laugh like beat until his
teeth fall out it's going to be harmful
to watch he's not well I think he's a
decent guy I think he cares about people
I think he is a little bit senile he
forgot Obama's name he's forgetting how
to talk often he just recently said ll
Beach LGBT OBGYN like he was he said
this this is not a function of you know
it's it's but it's kind of sad because
the guy suffered through a lot he's had
family tragedies I wish him not I make
fun of the son but I don't think he's a
bad person and even this all of this
even if the eruption were all true it's
hardly bad by political standards
everyone does this kind of stuff so I do
feel bad for him number one so I think
Trump would wipe the floor with him with
Sanders if you had two
anti-establishment figures which I don't
think there's historic precedent for in
the States at least not for like a good
80 years I don't know what it would look
like I don't I I mean I think it would
be I think the big loser there would be
media and social media would really
seize power because both of these
figures Trump and Sanders are very very
social media driven and
anti-establishment in every kind of
sense Hillary you know this is this
lovely woman who Sanders endorsed and
campaigned for just recently said no one
likes Bernie and he's never gotten
anything done very gratuitously well
that gives him an opportunity because
that means he's not beholden to you guys
and he is in a position to be like we
tried it your way
Hillary lost to the worst person in
history an election she should have won
we have this jackass now we're trying it
my way and that's a very compelling
message I feel mmm so you think that if
if there's no roadblocks put in place
that you could actually see Bernie
getting through it's conceivable but III
think the this would be kind of the I
can't think of another election
America's had that would have been this
kind of messy
other than like William Jennings Bryan
and and McKinley in like 1896 like it
would be
oh no no 68 68 you had three parties you
had Richard Nixon you had George Wallace
the southern racist figure and then you
had Hubert Humphrey from the Democrats
and they were riding at the Democratic
convention and it was basically at close
to its high in the popular vote between
Nixon and Humphrey and Nixon was reviled
by the Democrats understandably it was a
very very very dark election this would
be I think somewhat similar it's like to
south ends of a magnet right yeah you
get that and it's just really everything
yeah yeah yeah it would be really really
horrific in a good way
I love the carnage if you uh if you were
an Avenger do you think he'd be low-key
well locusts on the Avengers he's an
enemy I'm a DC Comics person okay but
I'm very much a trickster figure so yes
lucky than the Norse God not lucky the
combo character got you got you okay
who's your favorite DC guy oh girl I'm a
big I I was no one I'm a hipster so no
one's gonna have heard of this but I was
a huge fan of the Legion of super-heroes
I have every issue ever if they took
place in the 30th century and there was
a character they're called trouble good
girl so you have Superboy you have
Supergirl
you have Saturn girl whose telepathic
cosmic boy magnets Lightning Lad and
triplicate girl can just split into
three people and it's like okay this guy
can juggle the Sun and it's like
okay there's three chicks here and it's
just like light why are you here so this
triplets okay so I love that and one of
them then one of her bodies is destroyed
so she just became duo damsel so it's
like okay we have people here like
change like heat and electricity and
light and then there's like twins okay
twins who sometimes become Siamese twins
yeah it's like alright like I guess you
can fight this like witch who can
destroy the universe have you ever seen
that Family Guy episode where they all
get they all get infected with nuclear
waste and Meg's power is that she can
grow her fingernails really fast yeah
yeah that was before they canceled the
show and brought it back yeah yeah and
they had the Dallas ending yes yes they
did yeah yeah yeah look Michael I've
taken up in a few day man Twitter's
calling you people want to come in
people won't come and spiteful and give
you some money online where do they go
what do they do
Michael MELAS calm slash contribute but
I'm on Twitter and if you're ever in the
state's come and be in my show man
Brooklyn right yes there was quite a
minion in Manhattan I have every single
day there is another reason for me to
come out every single day I would love
to show you Brooklyn and here's why
because we don't have like reality honks
like with accents here not parade me
around the streets Michael I absolutely
want to see what like and what the
reaction is and I bet you there be some
low-key hostility I'm ready for it I'm
right with you protecting me no but you
can protect yourself yeah you know gonna
and you go to the gym you can handle it
fantastic well that'll do thanks man you
know what to do like share and subscribe
if you've got any comments or feedback
leave it in the comments below
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you